[موسيقى]
هذه الصور الحية
التي تؤكد الحياة من
إبداعات الفنانة لندن
سارة حزقيال
بينما تتمتع بالاعتراف
الدولي بعملها ،
تعاني سارة أيضًا من التصلب
الجانبي الضموري ،
مما يعني أنها لا تستطيع التحدث أو
تحريك
صورها يتم إنتاجها بشق الأنفس
بجلطة متعمدة باستخدام
حركة عينيها عندما أقوم بالإنشاء ، أركز
تمامًا على عملي
وتختفي جميع مشاكلي
ويسعدني أن لدي مكانًا للهروب منه
يعرف باسم الفنانة سارة التي تستخدم
تقنية الأشعة تحت الحمراء التي
تتعقب  حركات
تلاميذها للتحكم في فأرة الكمبيوتر على لوحة المفاتيح ،
مما يمنحها منصة للتعبير
الفني وأيضًا للتواصل حرفًا
بحرف ، هذه هي الطريقة التي يتم بها تشكيل الجمل ،
وهو عمل يستغرق وقتًا طويلاً ولهذا
السبب قمت بإرسال أسئلة المقابلة الخاصة بي إليها
مسبقًا  من اجتماعنا
حتى تأخذ وقتًا لإعداد إجاباتها
سارة كيف يمكنك تعديل أسلوبك الفني
ليناسب هذه التقنية
أعتقد أن الرسم مختلف تمامًا عن
استخدام يدي وقد جربت
كثيرًا ما زلت أشعر أنه منحنى تعليمي
مع كل لوحة ولدي
وفرة من التقنيات لاستكشاف
الشيء الغريب هو أن أسلوبي لم
يتغير ونظراتي  يشبه
العمل العمل الذي قمت به بيدي قبل
أن أعتقد أن هذا مجرد نظام استثنائي
لمثليي سارة من صنع
شركة التكنولوجيا الفائقة الدولية
توبي داينافوكس المتخصصة في أجهزة تتبع العين ،
وهناك مجموعة من
التقنيات المساعدة في السوق ،
بعضها يستخدم حركة العين والبعض الآخر  باستخدام
أجزاء مختلفة من الجسم ،
على سبيل المثال
عالم الفيزياء النظرية الذي تم التخلي عنه عالميًا
وزميله المريض ستيفن هوكينغ ، كان
يتحكم في برنامج حديثه
مع وجود عضلة في خده.
في عام 2015 في
العرض الأول لفيلم سيرته الذاتية
، تُعرف نظرية كل
شيء أحيانًا باسم مرض الخلايا العصبية الحركية
وفقًا لجمعية als ، فإنه
يؤثر على شخصين من بين كل
مائة ألف شخص في
المتوسط ولم يكن هناك عل
ج معروف كانت حياتي طبيعية جدًا قب
تشخيصي بأنني كن
أمًا بدوام كامل تستخدم للطهي ال
ظيف والذهاب إلى صالة الألعاب الرياضية با
تظام  بعد ولادة ابني
وسرعان ما أصبحت معتمدًا تمامًا على
مقدمي الرعاية في كل شيء
كوني والدًا لطفل حديث الولادة ،
وكان طفلي البالغ من العمر ثلاث سنوات مكانًا مخيفًا
ومعزولًا بالنسبة لسارة ، فقد أمضيت سنواتي الخمس الأولى مع mnd بدون جهاز كمبيوتر
والذي كان بمثابة  برية قاتمة بالنسبة
لي شعرت بالوحدة الشديدة لم أستطع القراءة لأن
يدي لم تعمل ولم أستطع إنشاء
أي شيء بعد
20 عامًا وهي الآن تعتبر
نفسها محظوظة
لأن أطفالها يكبرون وقد وجدت إطلاقًا علاجيًا من
خلال الرسم
كيف غيرت التكنولوجيا المساعدة
حياتك
كفنانة جعلت التكنولوجيا بالتأكيد
حياتي تستحق
أن أعيشها قبل أن أتأمل أنا لا أستطيع أن أبتكر بعد أن
أنظر ، أنا الفنان الذي كنت أرغب دائمًا في أن
أكونه  لا أصدق أنني أستطيع الرسم
بعيني